hi everyone I didn't know what the
audience would be I decided to assume
nothing so apologies to the people for
whom this is going to be a rerun of you
know but maybe maybe everybody will see
something new at least the cartoon or
something and and this this this doesn't
work [ __ ] ok so I'm going to begin with
the absolute basics and take us through
and I'm going to give a very very fast
very high level overview of this whole
area of interactive coding which I hope
will play some role in as we build in
sort of engineering solutions to how to
do stuff in real time and distributed
settings but this is really just to be a
theory talk and we can maybe in response
to questions we can get into how things
would you know play into application
areas but coding Theory begins with
Shannon I memorialized nicely here in
buy a stamp about Alexander Graham Bell
saying you're using the first electronic
communication system these are of course
very noisy so the question that came up
you know already before Shannon was how
do we deal with errors but there are sir
to questions that come in tandem and in
China was really the one to connect them
so the the really trivial question is
just well no noise at all ah I have a
child could submit can transmit one bit
at a time how I'll just take me to send
n bits this is a trivial question take
your time n but then the somewhat less
trivial question is you know just stir
maybe it is almost a modeling question
having an understanding that like our
fundamental idea of a noisy channel the
most the simplest maybe model is a
channel with stochastic noise and the
simplest thing is you should think of
memoryless noise of course information
has gone way beyond this so forth but in
case you know people really haven't seen
these basic things this is the the
simplest most basic model of annoyed
the channel you have an input that's a
zero or one and then with probability
epsilon might flip that before it comes
out the other end at the at the receiver
it's called a binary symmetric channel
width parameter epsilon and it's not the
easiest channel to deal with but it's
maybe the simplest to talk about and how
do you encode a single bit so that you
get very low probability of error well
you just take your bit and repeat it
many many times okay so that's called
the repetition code and if you want to
get exponentially small error
probability then this is a basic large
deviation bound that the right amount of
time is a linear and n okay so Shannon
asked well what if I don't have one you
know bit to send but many I have n bits
to send so I have a source that's
generating sort of a lot of data and
bits that's my message I have a
transmitter and now this whole block of
bits is going to go across the channel
and be affected by noise right so this
is the sort of the noise hitting the
channel and then there's a receiver and
the receiver gets to sort of decode
before the messages that you used at its
destination and the question now is when
I have a lot of bits how does this
problem scale up the kind of trivial
answer is well you can just still take
your bits encode them one at a time and
then that will make you if you have n
bits and you want to get error
probability e to the minus n for each
one of them then your total
communication time we'll go up to and
squared which is not so nice because you
have this the rate the you know bits per
unit time is going going to zero up till
Shannon that was what people knew but
thats you know really not the right
scaling and shines in sight you know one
way nice way of thinking about is that
there's just a lot a lot of room in high
dimension okay and there's so much room
that you don't really have to pay
separately except in the constants for
both sending many bits and getting a
very
error probability and this is in a
nutshell that Shannon's theorem that for
any positive alpha there's a code that
converts a message of length and two
well there's two ways to think of it you
can still think of a binary alphabet in
many characters in this case I can be
easier to think about sort of large
finite alphabets in which case it
doesn't matter you can just keep n the
same and this code will have the
property that's nonetheless the distance
between code words is still this
constant fraction alpha event so you can
get the same up two constants the same
behavior you got for the repetition code
even though you actually have
exponentially many code words and not
just two so that's what's summarized in
points a and B here there's a rate
guarantee you're sending your bits
across a positive rate which is
basically 1 over log of the size of the
alphabet and the error guarantee it
being exponentially small probability of
error so this is fine and classic and
you know the bedrock for the information
of coding theory for the situation when
you have a long message right at the
start does in the diagram Shannon's and
you get to encode it before shipping it
across that's not a real time kind of a
problem though and this method which is
called block coding isn't useful isn't
isn't you can't apply it if the data is
being generated in real time and in this
talk i will discuss three situations an
order of difficulty in which data is
actually generated in real time the
scenario one is sort of that with
respect to the with respect to the
transmitted the transmitter sort of
passive so somehow this this data is
actually being generated in real time
from outside of the transmitter by some
exogenous sort of source of data so the
the you know the DJ you know the
encoding in your cell phone treats your
human speech as some exotic you know it
doesn't it doesn't try and speak for you
it waits to hear what you said and
transmit some version of that and in
fact in cell phones we we do use
something called convolutional codes
which is a sort of a quasi well it's a
real time code it's it's not very
sophisticated one sense that the actual
block length being used the actual error
probabilities are not very low which is
fine for just dealing with something
like human speech so but doesn't this
this kind of simple approach doesn't
really scale up to getting you sort of
arbitrary Exponential's the more kind of
sophisticated scenario to in which we
deal with data being generated on the
fly is it can occur not for exogenous
regions for you know you sure have a
closed system but but you still have
this issue of essentially message being
generated on the fly and that is where
you're trying to implement over noisy
channels the communications designed for
a noiseless channel that we're going to
be run in an interactive communication
protocol okay so now you have two
processors so this is the basic scenario
of communication complexity for those of
you who are not theorists this might be
new the the basic model for
communication complexity is there two
processors each one of them receives one
of these two inputs their two inputs X
and Y one party receives X the other
part of why they would like to compute
some function f of x and y and people
communication complexity have the
library of favorite functions to worry
about and for the purpose of this talk
those two parties are going to be called
calvin in the librarian i will argue
these should be their historic names not
not not Allison Bob Calvin the librarian
so these two process you have between
them a physical channel and then each
round of their interaction there's a one
character from the alphabet Sigma can
can can fly and they just exchanged and
for the purpose of this talk I'm not
going to worry about and people do worry
about these things not going to worry
about what happens you know if we don't
all turn eight turns or if we have some
physical child which can some house like
you know wireless we can somehow sit
signals going both ways
not going to worry about those things we
have dedicated channel and I'm not going
to worry about for most of the talking
won't say anything about Constance so it
doesn't matter that we give each of them
a separate round and so forth okay so in
the goal at the end of the protocol just
what does it mean to succeed it means
that Calvin learns the value of this
function f of x and y okay and the end
we want to minimize the number of bits
that are they have to be communicating
or two to achieve this you notice what
the main thing about this problem is
that the amount of communication
required could be much much less than
that required to transmit why right
there's a sort of trivial solution where
the librarian ships over all of why but
that's that's not the solution that's
interesting you often you can get by
with with much less and the same setting
you know comes up in distributed
controls if you have several processors
trying to coordinate what they're doing
but they're also continually receiving
you know their own fresh data that's
more of an exogenous situation okay so
this is the the basic problem and it's
named the Calvin and the librarian
problem by me I guess I should admit
because of this okay so so if you'll
look here at one of the classics of
twentieth-century literature we have
Calvin this is calvin calling the county
library and asking for the reference
desk and saying why I need a word
definition and it's like one of those
cartoons you don't hear the voice of the
librarian guys squeaking in the
background but the librarians but then
Calvin responds well that's the problem
I don't know how to spell the word and
I'm not allowed to say it could you just
rattle off all the swear words you know
and then I'll stop you when okay hello
hello and see if I ever vote for their
tax levies okay so so what's what's the
problem that Calvin has here so what's
the sensible protocol for learning the
definition of the word
so here's a little by part that graph
I'm going to serve illustrate to you in
a way I'm not really about for that
graph anyway here's a diagram they're
they're all the words of the English
language suitably broadened to include
the kind of words calvinism she didn't
and and here are all the word
definitions they served down here and
the sensible protocol looks like this
Calvin says his word darn and then the
librarian responds with a definition for
example that's not quite a I mean that's
taking out further afield zama but but
that's not a word definition so how how
it so what's the librarian supposed to
respond with hmm yes very very very very
good very good dude this is this is what
Calvin probably did not have in mind but
this is a PG talk so the librarian spot
you know could respond with this with
this response this would be the sensible
protocol but Calvin can't implement it
for the reasons described previously so
instead Calvin would like to implement
the following protocol where the
librarian just says all these
unspeakable things and he just listens
to ok so this is this is now you can see
that this is a besides be more
entertaining a much more communication
intensive protocol right so it's a much
slower way of obtaining eventually of
Calvin eventually learning f of X and Y
where X is X is X is just the word darn
and why is actually this entire database
down here ok so um so Papa nutrient sips
are we're interested in the carbon and
librarian problem although they as I
checked recently we're not aware of its
true origin and they prove the following
theorem for all k grave equal to 24
infinitely many T there's a
communication problem that if you allow
yourself k round
of communication you can solve it very
quickly with just or very few very
little communication just K times log T
bits but if you insist on using only
only k minus 1 rounds of communication
and require it requires essentially a by
exponential blow-up in a number of bits
of communication you go from the log T 2
2 2 T and they they prove this for the
case k equals 2 which is exactly the
example I gave you a Calvin the
librarian and then they conjectured this
for 40 k and then it was proven a few a
few later years later okay yes um no I
don't know anything about that they
don't know anything about that I have to
think it maybe in a few years later so
this is all for deterministic protocols
but the same the same thing holds for
even if the protocol there's the same
the same round gap if you even if you
allow randomization of the protocols ok
so the kind of the out take from from
all this is that you really in order to
be efficient to communication really
need to have a high level of interaction
even if there's not a no issue of
exogenous you know real-time sources of
data I just it's an inherent it's an
inherent obstacle and communication
theory and you really need to be able to
to have very highly interactive
protocols for some problems which just
bring us to the problem of how to do
error correction are for general
interactive protocols the naive solution
is to apply the standard classical
Shannon block coding to every round but
as we just saw those in order for the
communications to have been efficient
for the noses protocol those rounds
might have had to have been very short
okay but that defeats the whole kind of
deep idea under under underlying block
coding idea which is that you need your
messages to themselves belong in order
to sneak in the era correct
along with the communication so and that
would require us to slow down the
communications by a you will get this
thing kind of quadratic slow down that
we talked about in the trivial solution
but there is a way to avoid this problem
it's just the block coding is not that
way so there is a theorem that goes like
this I give you an arbitrary you know
interactive protocol that terminates
with in T transmissions for any for any
pair of inputs it may be completely
interactive so it may use in fact T
rounds of communication just as it's
using two bits and we can talk about
either kind of error model and we'll
talk about both of these during the talk
one is adversarial noise that there's an
adversary it just goes in and is sort
can choose some alpha fraction of the
bits to flip whenever he chooses to or
there's the more the gentler and still
quite useful case of random noise or
stochastic channel that would like the
binary symmetric channel we saw before
and either way you get so the course the
random noise is easier to deal with but
either way you get a theorem that looks
like this well there's two theorems are
serve a randomized protocol
deterministic protocol that says that
there's a the first one says if you use
shared randomness you can still use just
a linear number of transmission so
you're sort of working a constant rate
finite alphabet channel so we're not
cheating in terms of the size of the
alphabet and achieves error probability
that goes down it's not quite e to the
minus T although that's been achieved by
now but at the time is e to the minus T
over poly log T and is also
computationally efficient this is with
shared randoms and the main ingredient
in the proof and I mentioning these sort
of old results because we have better
results in nowadays but actually many of
the methods the we'll be talking about
this come you know or persist so the the
main idea here is that once note you
serve do your communications as you is
if we're everything we're noiseless and
once a while you pause and you
you can send hashes of your entire
transcript and you compare these hashes
and if you need to use sort of backtrack
and in order to the the hardest part of
this whole business is sort of
synchronizing the two processes when you
back up you know what what part of our
history are we issuing a hash are we
having now you know so that that's the
main problem is this synchronization so
you have this sort of binary hierarchy
of checkpoints that's in you know 30
seconds the how the how the kind of
hashing method works so that's one
method that people use till today for
this kind of a problem and it requires
randomness for the hashing there's
another kind of class of solutions that
doesn't work that way at all and it
gives you a deterministic protocol and
again it works at constant rate so the
total amount of transmissions is still
linear in in the original number of
transmissions and still uses fine
alphabet so we're still not cheating it
works both in the adversarial and the
random noise case so this was just this
old resolves a stochastic noise this
works also in adversarial noise up to
some noise threshold which at the time
was one over into 240 or else it
achieves exponentially small error
probability and here the method is quite
different in is based upon a nucleus of
well now it's 23 years old but a class
of codes called true codes which I'll
say a little bit about and then on top
of the tree code so you can think of
this as like since we have some networks
people in the room there's like a
different layers so there's a code loyal
error which is tree codes and then
there's a simulation protocol that rides
on top of that so you have to kind of
put these two together so this is kind
of where this business starts and what
I'm going to do now in this talk time
permitting who's my chairman and I'm
don't have a chairman okay I'll just
talk
okay thank you I'm going to talk about
mainly the structure of the top from now
on is going to be okay we the servicer
so we start now there are roughly five
major kind of research directions that
people have taken this since then i'm
going to give some kind of an idea of
what what what has happened and where
things might go and i'm going to there's
a lot of papers here i'm i'm not going
to mention most of them or or i might
mention them like this where you know
but as a single out a few a few i think
are kind of key results and tell you
what what's been happening so so one
thing which was a great paper is this
result by bravoman and rao five years
ago where they dealt with this
deterministic protocols and they were
interested in the noise threshold
against an adversary so 100 200 1 over
240 is a constant so I was you know can
all be very happy with that but it's not
clearly the right constant and they made
a huge leap and got us basically to the
right content now asking whether it is
exactly the right constant begins to
depend on details I mean that this is
maybe some factor of 2 at stake
depending whether your binary alphabets
and this and that so I won't get into
that but they but they basically Gus to
the right regime and probably the right
answer certainly the right answer in
some models and maybe the riots or in
others for the arrow threshold so so
it's incredible kind of statement you
can be sitting here doing your one day
at a time interaction an adversary can
corrupt anything less than one-quarter
of your channel transmissions and you
still will see your protocol will still
succeed okay and notice that you know if
the adversary went up to a half he could
just block all the transmissions from
one of the parties okay so so we're so
we're we're sort of at the and if and if
he only goes not to one half but to
one-quarter he can flip half of the bits
of one of the parties
which means that that party is
essentially sending no information so
you can see why this is sort of the
right answer so so they get this except
that except that whoops except that yeah
not not accept anything okay that's the
that's the reason ok so this solution I
just described to you this kind of
protocol layer description in the
previous slide of the old result this
simulation this this theorem i should
say respect that structure it leaves
tree codes intact and it uses a
completely different simulation protocol
riding on top of the tree code is very
great very nice idea now it's not
computationally efficient i really
should have said when i was doing the
previous slide I bothered to point out
one of the reasons of you mentioning the
randomizer I mentioned the why mention
the randomized think it's weaker well
it's not weaker because it's
computationally efficient and this is
not okay so their result is still not
computationally efficient but i should
say the only thing that is not
computationally efficient is that we
don't know how to build tree codes and
we don't know how i'll say exactly what
we want in a no a slight or so but sort
of their contribution is computationally
efficient and there's some things that
we still don't know how to do that rides
on top of there are interesting very
interesting questions that would that
could make it possibly a efficient
there's a whole list of paper as I don't
even think I've got all the listed here
they have to do with uh changing this
one quarter two different numbers
depending on different models of the
channels
channels and adaptivity to who speaks
next it's a it's a bit complicated okay
so that's 11 line of research another
wire research that's been people will be
developing is um what exactly is the
channel capacity so so this was already
clear in in the early 90s so so you know
of course well again I'm going to assume
people no don't do so if you don't know
this stuff I'm just going to tell you
from most people in the room I think
this is very very well known you know
when we talk about one way
communications if we have a binary
symmetric channel or any discrete any
sort of noise to have a channel but
certainly for a binary symmetric channel
we know exactly what's the maximum rate
of communication you can achieve has
it's very pretty representation is one
minus the log base 2 entropy of epsilon
the error probability and you can
communicate at any rate just below that
and you cannot communicate their and
above so we know that but it already
seemed back in the 90s that that could
not be the right answer for interactive
communication because what happens in
interactive communication is you you
have you have the phenomenon we've
probably all encountered when you talk
to someone in a very noisy environment
you start saying something and they say
you know they they can tell that they
weren't getting things right then they
have to ask you to roll back all right
and then you have to the rollback and if
you don't roll back they misunderstand
what you're saying and and then the film
event on the communications are kind of
wasted if you think of the the branching
of a protocol tree where I say something
and then depending what I say use that
say something and depending what I heard
I you know it every player the next
thing that they say depends where they
think they are in this protocol tree
right the problem is if I misunderstand
where I am in the protocol tree what I'm
saying is completely irrelevant I mean
even if you later understand that oh I
should ignore that communication you
have to roll back and repeat it it
doesn't convey any useful information
that's relevant to the actual way we're
going in our interaction whereas in in
one and you know there's not this
problem in in one way communication of
it seemed that there's this inherent
problem in the interactive
communications that because there's a
because you need to react because of the
real-time problem because I need you
need when you're responding to react to
very recent things very recent things
cannot have been error corrected to very
low error ability very distant past you
may buy now be very sure of but the last
thing that you just said that you can't
possibly have error corrected that very
well yet so I'm going to occasionally
misunderstand you and I'm going to
occasionally respond inappropriately
mainly I'm responding about some part of
the tree that we shouldn't be even
exploring and then we're gonna have to
roll back and redo that okay so that's
an extra overhead that simply doesn't
exist in the wood for one-way
communications and it seemed 20 years
ago that that was inherent proving that
was very hard but was finally achieved
just a few years ago by Gerrit Cole and
run Russ where they actually proved that
the four interactive communications
instead of the correct instead of the
one-way bound of one minus the entropy
of epsilon being the communication rate
it act it's actually somewhat worse and
the scales like one minus square root up
to a constant of of the entropy of
epsilon and they also have a ballot from
from the other side this is really the
main the meeting accomplishment
so that's a that's a that's a really
kind of I think important so I mean we
don't you know of course we really only
understand this for small epsilon we
don't have the beautiful picture that we
have you know for all channels for for
one-way communications and I don't know
when we should expect that but be might
be possible okay so that's that's a
second direction I want to talk about
the the third direction I want to talk
about is um the this issue of
computational tractability so so far the
only situation I mentioned in which we
had something computationally tractable
so which have been doing with
communication complexity I've been
talking about the computation that you
need north to implement the protocol was
only the case of you know stochastic
channels with randomized protocols which
is like the kindest environment and
other than that wouldn't have anything
but in this sequence of papers that were
later merged into one broker ski and
calayan or gave still randomized
protocols but those randomized protocols
can deal with an adversarial noise up to
a pretty decent threshold not quite as
good as the rough for Monroe but still
um pretty high the computational
complexity can be made okay there's a
slight difference in models here if you
want to really get to know over 32 they
have quadratic time computation but you
can get some positive constant even with
us with come with n log n computation so
it's it's um it's really nice and
interesting Lee you know the same kind
of class of ideas work but it's harder
to put them together it so it's a lot of
work you still use sort of tree codes
for your short term communications you
can afford that the problem with tree
codes is the computation time scale
exponentially in the depth of the tree
but you can get away with this four
times proportional to log in and then
you hash as sort of a layer on top of
that and then this was pushed even
further along by bernard coupler i guess
about a year or so later who gave a
randomized protocol
and he was interested in the low noise
regime okay so he's interested in what
happens you know there's there's there's
sort of you know bad constant sort of
you know or not that bad but a real
constant sort of involved sort of any
everywhere in this in this they oh i
should say there's an implicit content
item to talk about here which is the
size of the alphabet okay so it's like a
constant size alphabet but he was
interested in you know also where you
know worried about the whole thing so
he's talking about binary alphabet which
has a very small though error
probability and in that case he could
get uh he conjectures this is the right
number down to the log log communication
rated so so this is kind of a very this
is like the only example I think that we
have in in in this sort of story that
begins to resemble results that we have
in classical sort of information theory
of where we we know we really get the
right function it's not quite though
because of these constants but at least
the ideas that we're getting the the
correct scaling this and i should say
the it's also true of the the coal Roz
and in their case too they have
something that looks a little different
it's one minus the square root of the
entropy function so sorry so both of
those results are results where we think
that at least up to police the scaling
is really the correct scaling yeah
so that's actually a good question in
the in the in the gillet in the cold Roz
result there it's not and they sort of
get the right answer for that and if
you'll notice there's this curious thing
here which is that he beats they're
bound so they're bound was square root
of the entropy of epsilon which is
growing faster as a function of epsilon
so this number is actually smaller and
that's how we can beat their bow because
they're bound is tight up two constants
the I mean the second order this term is
tied up the constants in there around
but because of that activity you can
actually beat their bout so this is
pretty yeah
okay the the the the hard work here is
actually more of the analysis it's
pretty hard rather than the protocol
because somehow the protocol still has
this structure of the original
randomized protocol of you have a new
hash these checkpoints and you have a
binary hierarchy of checkpoints and you
kind of creates like meeting points for
the two parties to to be hashing the
same transcript and then to move forward
when they find agreement it's the same
kind of structure but the impressive
thing here is you can actually analyze
how that protocol behaves the envy even
against an adversary not just against a
stochastic channel okay and then there's
a more recent result that does something
but it's not quite constant rate for
even even the deterministic case but
it's not quite the same
the direction for I want to talk about
is about tree code so there's some how
their this important object that's
underlying a you know the everything
that's deterministic in this in this
story there have been some you know we
don't know how to build there has been
some results i'll briefly mentioned
there's an additional after the
originally just these things exist
that's a good thing but we don't know
how to build them we know how to build
them with pretty small alphabets we know
how to build variants that don't work
for full generality work for particular
classes of applications we know how to
build a weaker object called a potent
tree code actually we don't know how to
build those but those at least have the
property that if you sample when it
random it will be one where the tree
codes even if you sample a random they
are they aren't one recently oh i should
say i don't think i have it on the
slides there's a very recent kind of
unpublished result of sudan and yellow
clay saying that after you can get full
strength free codes with high
probability to so this has recently been
matched even for tree codes there's a
there's a construction that sort of in
quasi exponential time whatever you want
to call that kind of a function but the
alphabet scales / and then there's a
conjectural construction but chris
morran myself from a couple of years ago
which we don't know if it you know we
which may may be a construction depends
on some conjecture and analytic number
theory building these building these is
to me the most beautiful open question
in this area it may not be the most
important one as i wrote on the slide to
me it's the most important one that's
certainly the most beautiful so i guess
it's a little bit on how much time i
have some slides that actually describe
tree codes and the problem here oh but
how am I I have 10 minutes well I can we
can we can get some coffee and continue
learn so outside so okay so i'll tell
you about tree codes arm just because i
mentioning him so much I'd like I know
some people is all hat but not everyone
I think so so what are they they're
they're strictly stronger object in a
block code a tree code is this let t be
the infinite binary tree with root
so we're going to call the root epsilon
it's an infinite binary tree complete
now everybody has two children the
vertices are labeled by finite strings
in 01 so the vertices just tell you zero
and says go left when one tells you go
right so forth okay and we'll think of
this tree as a metric space where we
take two vertices we ask about the
distance to know but it's not a standard
metric space we actually only care about
the distance between two vertices if
they are at the same level so it's going
to be a meaningless question to ask
about distance between vertices
otherwise okay and the distance between
them is just going to be the graph
distance which is the distance well or
half which half the graph distance or
the distance from either of these
vertices to their least common ancestor
okay so that's the tree the the sort of
graphical distance between these two
points so in this I've picked out two
favorite verses X and Y which are the
strings I guess I'm one means go to the
left 100 or 110 and their distances to
okay so that's just the tree there's no
code here is to make this a code you
take some finite alphabet and you write
down some letter of the alphabet at
every vertex of the of the tree okay
that makes it into a code in the
following way so alpha alpha is the code
alpha is a mapping from vertices of the
tree into your finite alphabet once you
have a letter written on every vertex of
the tree you now get words you if you
start at the root and read down going to
some path so here you would see a BB
okay and now you can look at the Hamming
distance between two of these words so
for x and y why was the string a BB X
was the string ACA now what you want
this thing this coat with this this
labeling alpha to satisfy an orifice be
to be a tree code is that that that
these two functions should be roughly
the same so the the distance on the
words it should be the same as the
graphical distance in the tree up to
some factor okay so that makes it a
trick coat so you want the the the the
resisting the Hamming distance between
these two words to be at least a
constant fraction of s here where s was
the was the distance to the common gases
okay so that makes this a tree code oh
is it shouldn't be clear that you have a
unique Dakota mean so if i have an
arbitrary labeling of the nodes of the
tree the alphabet is there necessarily
unique distance between the because of a
because there isn't necessarily just one
vertex that corresponds to that string
over the alphabet well I mean if you
don't have any kind of assumption about
the labeling then I mean you could just
use it that's what you're I understand
the question look at your understand
my guess is more try and understand
the mini to our nothing in the right
direction so good okay okay yes if
you're happy I'm happy but I can also
answer the question if you're not but
I'm not quite sure I understand the
question and the question was I think if
there can't be two nodes in the same
level two different nodes that have
exactly the same label well okay again I
mean I can label everything in the tree
with the letter A and then again nothing
but it wouldn't be a tree code for
positive see so we want some positive
see um okay so old theorem these things
exist um the it's sort of not quite
trivial versions of proofs by the
probabilistic method Oh is a dimension
killeen Sudan have actually improved she
gets high probability so at the time it
was just there exists with some positive
probability not with overwhelming
probability but now it's been been fixed
but the problem is that actually we
don't even know how to verify it so so
now at least thanks to this result of
killeen so then that you can actually
generate one and it's probably fine and
you still can't check in sub exponential
time I mean it sniffing object but we
always think of like cutting it off a
depth end and it still then then it's
easy to see that you can check this in
exponential time but we don't do not
know anything better than that okay so
so what do I mean by an effective
construction it is an exponential sized
object so you can you can argue well
what's the problem with checking in
exponential time it's an exponential
sized object if I take it down to depth
in the problem is it you only use it for
protocols that that run like time n you
only Explorer serve you know vertically
you don't explore the whole breadth of
one of the things when you're using them
so what we really mean is that if I give
you an address I give you an address and
the tree you should tell me the label
written there in time proportional
polynomial in the depth of that vertex
actually want a little bit more to
really use these things to be full
strength if I give you a string of
length and you should be able to find
the closest string to it in the tree
least you know we could do a promise
version where there exists something
close you should want to do that in tomm
polynomial time so if you if you have
of this I'll tell you I'll agree you
have an effective construction if you
have this then you can you're really
ready to to do it we don't know how to
do this we know how to do lots of other
things for those in you know people were
theoreticians you know we know about all
these like amazing progress has been
made including very recently on Ramsey
graph you know there's no and we have no
progress that we can demonstrate on this
do we only have this one thing that is
not obviously false ok that's the status
of that it's a great problem the fifth
kind of research thrust that I wanted to
talk about is the third scenario which
it didn't mention before so right maybe
just alluded scenario one was real-time
communications with serve exogenous data
I'm just still one way communication but
it's generating real-time scenario two
is two interacting parties scenario 3 is
many interacting parties and this is
perhaps the thing most likely to you
know be connected to maybe some of the
application areas relate to this
workshop so now the model is I have n
processors they have maybe m
point-to-point channels you can imagine
other kinds of topologies obviously but
this is what people been worrying about
so far each channel can carry just one
bit per round each and this slide I'm
just going to serve carefully defined
what the problem statement is the
problem is every processor starts with a
private input X sub I they're solving
some problem using a known distributed
protocol pi the way pi works is this up
till time teed the i'th processor has
some some transcript twice this is no
noise right I'm just talked about the
noises situation every processor has
received some long transcript of
everything received from his neighbors
up through time T it batches that all
together and then he applies the
protocol the protocol is a function of
his identity his input his transcript
and then it says to him what he should
send to each of his neighbors and the
protocol has run time capital T that's
when it by definition that's when it's
supposed to halt and correct output is
that every processor should be
holding the at the end of this process
the this particular transcript why y sub
I capital T okay and the question is how
can I take a completely generic
distributed protocol this type and
protected against noise so we did worry
about this problem back in the 90s as
well and had the following basic result
which there are now improvements of is
that again for stochastic channel so
every one of these channels is its own
binary symmetric channel with some
probability epsilon then you can take
the original protocol with Rannoch time
and ran in time capital T and just slow
down by a factor proportional to log n
where n was the number of parties again
okay and you'll still succeed with
exponentially high probability or if the
network had degree D then you would slow
down by lagdi logins just an upper bound
synchronous model so everything happens
sort of you know all our clocks are
synchronized and we just exchange wait
messages it's arm it's came up with some
other workshop recently so you just
mention that then the flavor of this
theorem it sounds like just a version
maybe of the two-party thing it's
actually it has a very different flavor
from the two-party version servant going
you sort of need obviously to party
versions but they sort of a new
phenomenon that happens which is that
when an error occurs it has lost it
starts propagating through the graph
like a like a wave and somehow the
problem is how to and you can't stop it
right so they're all these ripple
effects kind of and you have you can
detect an error has occurred and then
you start sending correction messages
but these things are happening sort of
simultaneously all at once you can
easily see that if you slow down but if
you if you dance if you did a lot more
local error correction you didn't slow
down by a constant local on each message
you could damp these things so that only
a few errors would occur but the
problems networks big and we don't want
to slow down like that so we actually
operate in a regime where errors are
happening and these waves of error are
beginning in the network all the time so
the interesting thing about this theorem
is actually that you have these waves
of error Corrections chasing waves of
errors and you have to show that these
things don't add up so did something
interesting going on this was um not a
effective in computation so a few years
ago there's a quite nice result that
showed that you can actually do this in
with poly time computation but this is
still all for stochastic channels and
what we were interesting at the time was
this issue of this log in slow down so
you can see there's something very
essentially different between this and
the two-party thing which is that we now
have not a constant but a log in hurting
us here and it seems that that was
necessary because of kind of a Union
bound sitting here as a processor I have
degree D there could be an error on
every channel coming in to me I just
tell you have to take the Union over
those things happening so i have to damp
the error a bit and it seemed that that
was necessary it also seemed empirically
to be quite a hard problem and was
finally solved just last year where
people show that in fact the distributed
case is though there is a real slow down
where well there's some log log in that
we still don't understand but basically
that log in is that is there is the
correct is the correct answer this is
still all for stochastic channels this
is only the worst case over networks in
fact that happens for the star network
or there's just one party in the middle
like a star connected and neighbors so
that's a network with very high degree
but very poor connectivity turns out if
you're in a network with high degree but
also good connectivity things are better
and this is thang roughly speaking
especially within the context of how
much time I have it's roughly I'll just
say it's a network coding kind of
approach you sort of broadcast and we
reconnect so you can you can then get
better computation tix
okay just two slides left people also
worried about adversarial noise in the
distributed setting the reason the truth
is sort of much worse and there was
adverse aerial noise you can't get these
solutions like it what I was just
describing in the ad for adversarial
noise the problem is the adversary can
go and focus all of his efforts to
destroy the communications coming out of
you know one processor something it
won't happen with stochastic noise and
so the scaling of the threshold for
noise that one can cope with is much
much worse in basically one over the
number of parties so that unfortunately
seems to be the truth but but there are
results are positive results up to that
level there's still a lot that we don't
understand there in particular although
the in particular there's a slowdown
factor there that is probably to my mind
probably not necessary which I can
describe to people later if anyone's
curious about this question
people are looking to a lot of other
things so this is just my grab bag of
other other kinds of this core
cryptogram you know the effects of noise
and communications and cryptographic
settings people have looked at people
have looked at what happens for channels
with the insertions and deletions of
channels where time is not synchronous
for the different parties we're
currently working at what happens sort
of a rate-distortion version of these
types of theorems and what I decided not
to focus on it all on this talk sort of
knowing that wouldn't have time to and
also that I'm really not an expert in it
is the the the role of communication
distributed control clearly the thing
that's you know most obviously connected
to everything I've talked about yeah and
hopefully one I just mentioned a few of
the names of control theorists who've
been served interested in the role of
communication information and control
and maybe we'll hear some point in our
next year I don't know from some of
these people
questions
okay I'll turn that down a means for
example yeah these girls and noise
between us need to cover the Cape Point
this is trimming came in support and we
never mentioned this time with ours and
they never mention quarter no wonder
what is there any connection because
it's the pawn something similar we ever
have information there is noise i want
to send you this vectors but it seems to
have nothing to do with information
several other forms seems with vitamin
but why is this and what am I missing
here that so you know sorry but Justin
you know you know k you know the case
sources exactly and it's giving it you
just send yo Gaza noise again it's it's
a one-way problem you have all the
information and I don't and uh you know
you can think of it as a rate-distortion
problem if you like and if you want to
get approximate locations if you want to
if you digitize this and want to send
them exactly it becomes a standard
coding theory problem you know we know
that interaction doesn't change capacity
for one-way communication so it can help
computation but doesn't actually change
capacity so these things come in though
the where you know take some version of
a problem where you have K points and I
have L whatever's and then then then
then the interaction becomes support the
first line of our channel with no I we
just want to send you some information
yeah but the first slide is not yeah
yeah another 19 slides you know the
house but work on so looking at the
error correction blow up in this last
setting for specific functions for
obviously for majority you can do much
better than parody or ma we imagine or
something by say anything like that so
I'm afraid okay and the noise of review
I say you want to say some of these
functions are just much more robust to
the channel noise maybe
the only okay so the only thing I can
think of it at all similar to that was
this paper I went by very quickly by
that rabbani Ostrovsky and Swami and
myself where we say for particular
problems in control but we're not in the
unstable regime of control we serve in
the in the borderline in case in control
so we have we have a plant that doesn't
it's not actively unstable it's
neutrally stable in that case the
problem you're solving doesn't have this
exponential growth growth of like a tree
code so they're so the Terry the
protocol nevermind the code the product
the protocol geometry doesn't look like
a tree it actually looks like a five
dimensional space so that's kind of a
gentle kind of problem to be solving and
in that case we can do better we have
you know computationally effective
solutions to these problems it doesn't
exactly fit the exam but that's the only
example I'm aware of where we have a
result of that flavor interactive codes
and distributed consensus algorithms and
justify can elaborate sent me that's why
mean the acela Leslie Lamport right
we're in the distributed consensus
algorithm which really strive for it's
not to get the probability of error
below some threshold but to get the
problem in order to be zero and it seems
like there's a natural trade-off here
between the time required to accomplish
that versus the probability of error so
it seems like you know you could trade
off the time dimension against the
probability of error we got a proximate
consensus using these kinds of
algorithms or exact consensus by trading
off the use of time has anyone looked at
the relationship between these
algorithms well I mean let me make sure
I'm understanding so
I've met arrangement is the question
could we more quickly get a much I'm
something without exponential or
probability is 0 at the at the expense
that the time it takes to accomplish the
communication may become unbounded but
you could bound it in some probability
yeah right so guarantee exact
communication but found the time it
takes to accomplish that with some error
program oh I see you want the zero error
but randomized time version of these
kinds of results no so so I think
usually there's spilling a pretty
automatic way of sort of compiling well
it depends what kind of channel mall
you're talking about I mean if the
channels are sarcastic then your error
probabilities just never going to be
zero because maybe every bit has been
corrupted okay you know that's not true
because you can I mean it you can trade
off time because this is what the
distributor in the limit okay so so you
can say that the three bunch of bounds
on the other toy the source of failure
yeah yeah sure that's what if ubound the
sources of error so i'll get most
one-third of the party but bet the
adversarial mom yeah so but many of the
results i described were precisely about
the adversarial model of error where I
say the adversary has only flipped alpha
fraction of the bits and then we said
there are these thresholds so if the
fraction was less than one-quarter then
the probability of error is 0 so that
that's what we know in this kind of a
setting
I had to go looking at precisely that
thing I was interested what's the
performance of the lamp or consensus
algorithm versus some other consensus
algorithm and what you're bringing up is
that the measurement of complexity that
people want who people are designed
industry which algorithms are in Sidon
one nation of complexity it seems to me
that the people designing communication
algorithms are interest in a different
measure and complexity so it's I was
interesting what's the real killer when
you're trying to write a distributed
with the number one for round trip times
and the two packet drop so you can take
let's say the Lamport consensus
algorithm say what are the asymptotics
of this algorithm as a function of P the
packet drop probability parametrized by
RTT the round-trip time and you can say
this algorithm has such and such a
complexity in terms of P and RTT and you
could do the same with let's say the
lamp or [ __ ] algorithm dusk how tight is
the clock pounds is a function of
network connectivity so so the error
model that makes sense for people
writing distributed algorithms i think
is to say don't worry about adversary's
because there aren't adversary's when
you're saying placards on the internet
at least i mean there are third but not
not not in this sense your adversary's
generally it is generally a packet drop
because butters get full and packet
latency because of routing variability
your crucial question is how robust is
my algorithm to those sources of error
and then then it's really fascinating to
ask how can I come up with the
measurement of complexity workwear
different algorithms really you showcase
the difference you work out the brittle
points of this algorithm versus that
over them
you know you I think you raise another
point which sure is another question in
my mind which is that you know your
notion of interactivity adds more to do
with how much data you get before you
reply but it doesn't have to do with the
latency of the communication but the
latency of the communication could be a
killer from yep yeah that's been assumed
the way here everything gets there in
one unit of time I totally agree right
yeah so I would be good to look I
okay thank you